I'm going to tell you right now about one of the
most disgusting abuses of police power that we
have seen in a while in terms of an anecdotal
individual story. Back on May 20th, I brought
you the story of Rebecca Jones from Florida. She
is the scientist who used to run the Florida covid
dashboard, and back in May, she was fired, as she
put it, because she refused to manipulate the data
to make it look better. In Florida, Republican
Governor Rhonda Santurce made the decision in
Florida to open up really early before it made
sense. And she was told she claims to sensor data
change. Other data make it seem as though the
premature opening in Florida was not actually
premature. She wasn't willing to do it. She says
that's why she was fired. This week, Rebecca
Jones's home was raided in a military style raid.
We have video of the raid. We're showing it to our
television audience. Police burst in, shouting,
pointing guns. Why were they there at all? Police
were serving a search warrant against Rebecca
Jones for a suspected computer crime. What is that
crime will remember she was fired for she says she
was fired for refusing to manipulate covid data.
The allegation is that after she was fired and
therefore was no longer a Florida state employee,
she logged onto the government messaging system
meant only for employees of the state of Florida
to send a message to her coworkers that she was
asked to modify the data and is refusing to do so.
And for that alleged crime of sending a
message, she was on the receiving end of
a militarized police raid of her home. Jones, by
the way, denies that she even did that. She says,
no, I went public. I, you know, wrote an op
ed in the Miami Herald. I spoke publicly,
but I didn't even do the thing I'm accused
of doing. So the immediate suspicion
was that this came from the top that Republican
Governor Ronda Santurce was behind all of
it to Santos has denied involvement. But now
the part that's becoming the focus is that the
raid was carried out in an obviously absurd way.
It's completely indefensible how this was done.
Police burst in with weapons. Jones is crying.
She's yelling that there's kids in the house,
that her husband is in the house. And Jones even
says police pointed guns at her kids. Police deny
that they pointed guns at her kids. Police are
saying, listen, Jones took a while to answer the
door. That escalated the level of aggressiveness
that we used. And the problem here is that the
problem is the paradigm of the raid at all.
What is tantamount to a SWAT team showing up
because someone is suspected of using an
employee only messaging system to send a message.
We can have a bigger debate about if and whether
militant militarized police raids should be used
for search warrants at all. But the debate would
be confined to people suspected of violent crimes,
high level crimes, people who are believed to
be risks of some kind or something else. Almost
no one with any semblance of common sense would
even say, let's debate whether an alleged crime
like this warrants a militarized police search
warrant serving. It's ridiculous and it's the
worst of the worst of the overuse of police power.
Now, the individual level at the individual level,
the officers themselves don't appear to have done
anything wrong. Certainly that will be provable
in terms of, you know, they pointed guns at my
kids. Police say they didn't, you know, unless
there's video of that. My point is not to excuse
the officers individual, but to explain that
they announced themselves. They secured people in
the house. They they roughly followed protocol in
these militarized raids. The problem is that
such a raid took place at all. The orders were
from whoever decided that this was the suspect.
And we're going in guns blazing. And the problem,
of course, is that the decision to execute this
in that way was made. That's the problem. And the
suspicion, of course, is this was retribution
against Rebecca Jones because she refused to
falsify covid data back in May to say that this is
over. Policing is not even a strong enough phrase.
If we saw this in another country, we would all be
saying this is an authoritarian, strong arming of
a whistleblower to intimidate them for exposing
that very government that went after them.
If we saw it elsewhere, that's what
we would be saying. Let me know your
thoughts. I want to hear from you.
I'm on Twitter at David Pakman, T